est ce que tu aimes patrick juvet
voilà
ce qu'on a je ne suis plus très bien car
les jurés
[Applaudissements]
et quelle belle catherine gillet
patrick c'était ici aujourd'hui en fait
c'est à 10 points pour l'indicé pour un
livre qui s'appelle les bleus au coeur
chez son rôle chez flammarion vous
racontez votre votre vie alors ça
commence en france très très ennuyeuse
au bord du lac léman des parents stricte
autoritaire qui ne savent pas vous
montrer leur amour en fait c'est ça
mon père surtout fouet puis ma mère elle
avait les deux rôles couette ouais alors
toute votre vie vous avez eu un immense
besoin d'amour c'est un peu comme toi
son père lui a jamais dit qu'il qu'il
aimait 1 je lui ai fait dire bien des
années plus tard 81 6 un jour vous êtes
au fond du trou et vous êtes avec lui
vous le dis moi que tu m'aimes et il
nous dit pas il l'a gagné et la pleurent
et voilà ils font linge et donc je
pensais que ça voulait dire oui
alors c'est dur d'avoir 15 ans à
montreux au bord du lac léman je pense
que c'est dur d'avoir n'importe quel âge
en suisse ouais
c'est vrai quand on aide est rangée est
réfugiés fiscaux qui c'est tout à fait
juste marina y va il a 15 ans il à
montreux il adore les stones les beatles
abbey de bowie et puis la vie en suisse
c'est terrible voilà après ce sont tous
installés en suisse voilà est alors un
jour à la sortie de l'école il ya un
homme qui vous attend au volant d'une
ferrari
bientôt il vous emmène en vacances à
positano à portofino et là vous
commencez une existence de rêve avec des
milliardaires célibataire si vous
échapper quand même à
cette vie de merde
j'avais envie de voir autre chose je
vivais dans un milieu très modeste et
j'avais envie de voir ce que c'était que
les palaces
la fourchette est à gauche le truc à
droite je papa et et j'ai appris tout ça
avec cette personne ouais
c'était quand même un choix
vous étiez au moujik suel ou pas je
savais pas encore ce que jamais oui vas
y avait des indices quand même
ma mère en question lundi chez vous et
non mais on n'a pas couché j'ai pas avec
les milliardaires non c'est ce qu'il dit
dans son livre en fait oui non ne leur
est pas couché ah bon j'étais pas mal il
était patient quoi ils étaient très
amoureux et je le remercie beaucoup donc
vous entrez à ce moment là dans une
école d'arts décoratifs à vevey et vous
laisser vite tomber parce que la seule
chose qui m'intéresse c'est de composer
de la musique est là votre père vous
trouve un boulot vous vous retrouvez en
blouse grise en train de vendre des
clous et des vis et des dix lévis c'est
mieux que les clous bah c'est pareil il
ya des mais y avait tellement de tiroir
c'était pas mon truc du tout
ces trois jours j'ai rendu là j'ai rendu
la blouse
alors l'âge de saison vous découvrez
votre sexualité votre bisexualité
premier garçon à 24 ans vous trouvé ça
un peu vieux mais vous dites il a une
bagnole quand même ben oui c'est
peut-être j'avais un solex jones après
c'était pas pareil j'irai si les taxis
je n'avais pas les moyens
voilà et vous devenez mannequin à ce
moment là et puis vous avez plus de
nouvelles de vos parents que ça durerait
des années quoi vous je suis parti en
allemagne à 18 ans et c'est vrai que
c'était un peu déçu ouais 110 ans fera
rien de lui ouais alors en 1970 vous
arrivez à paris et là vous tombez sur
florence aboulker qui était attachée de
presse qu'à 36 ans vous en avez 20 alors
au début vous vous dites bon voila vous
vous êtes intéressés par l parce qu'elle
peut vous aider mais c'est pas encore
une relation amoureuse et ça va le
devenir ça va le devenir et finalement
quand on lit votre bouquin on s'aperçoit
que cette florence avoue le cas a été le
seul vrai grand amour de votre vie en
fait c'est pour ça que j'ai fait de
livres ouest parce que comme elle a
disparu il ya trois ans deux ans et demi
et trois ans à bientôt
je sais pas j'avais pas fait le deuil du
tout
j'ai pensé qu'il fallait le mettre le
mettre sur page je les fais avec
quelqu'un de fantastique didier le cas
qui est le père de mathieu
et qui est décédé lui aussi oui c'était
un gros drame pour moi pour pas que pour
moi reste
alors en 1971 florence aboulker vous
présente barclays eddie barclay vous
signez un contrat vous installer chez
elle et 5,3 si vous installez chez elle
il ya ces enfants qui sont là
vivait avec elle vous continuez quand
même à sortir un peu la nuit avoir des
aventures un peu toujours way toujours
mais elle avait deux enfants de 9 ans et
11 ans donc ça brille ça vous le caylar
et qu'ils aient travaillé avec marc
lavoine qui a fait les chansons
magnifiques magnifique les yeux revolver
et là vous composer la musique à quai la
première chanson qu'on a entendues dans
dans le petit music story qu'on a qu'on
a passée à l'instant elle vous dit si de
la merde mais ça va marcher c'est à dire
que la première chanson que j'ai fait
c'est romantique pas mort les radios
l'aimé bien et c'était plutôt mon style
et
c'était romantique et en fait sa part
vendu et eddie barclay m'a dit le
prochain houssin tube ou durant trente
ans c'était l'enfer quoi c'était
l'époque des libertés n'est pas d'accord
allô
oui
liane tu sais que nous sommes en train
de faire l'émission la chauffe est
interviewé patrick juvet cela
peut très bien
non je me dérange pas eu hélène ségara
que là elle te déteste normale aux
élèves la baise
l'anel particulièrement quand même
assez salée chanteuse s'est fait
demander à patrick bellanger
qu'est ce que tu penses de bibelots ce
qu'est ce que tu penses de guy bedos
[Rires]
il est en face de l'île d'arros et
il a une à mes yeux qui pleurent mais
c'est pas l'émotion c'est là je dis non
c'est de la quinzaine
elle a pas d'amis
elle est où la bienvenue pour le non
mais c'est parce que j'ai envie de me
parler simplement ça tombe sur des
missions assez l'embarras c'est qui ces
lianes cody à ces liens oui la butte
[Applaudissements]
bon je te laisserais passer laine qui va
t'embrasse et puis moi je vais continuer
mon interview de patrick juvet qu'est-ce
qu'on était au moment où il découvre et
sa bisexualité est ou
non ça va
ça va ouais non non pas du tout à ça
tout le monde s'en mordait que j'irai
donc on est content que cela faire tu
veux être mignonne raccroche
non mais c'est un vrai coup de fil bon
c'est didier gustin qui se fait chez
un pote et moi
donc vous comprenez la musica et ensuite
alors les lundis au soleil pour claude
françois qui vous rapportent énormément
d'argent à ce moment là patrick juvet
patrie je sais pas c'est que tu es légué
un appel tamer détends toi
patrick juvet fait son premier olympia
et là c'est le
ski et le drame surtout c'est que
florence était absolument génial qu'elle
vend son appartement pour vous donner
les moyens de vivre votre aventure elle
vous présente le maquilleur de david
bowie en face à elle a vraiment été pour
vous pygmalion si on peut dire bien sûr
et là vous démerder de mettre enceinte
une petite gonzesses
oui
alain les gens se ressemblent
sauf que l'enfant n'est pas né alors oui
mais vous regrettez que l'enfant soit
pas né parce que finalement vous aurait
bien aimé avoir un enfant c'est génial
ouais ça va chantal
c'est laurent baffie tout va bien
ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est cherchons
et chantal je peux pas te parler tout
nous dérange là en fait
je t'aime pas patrick juvet
chantal lauby oui c'est nouveau genre
d'émission sur le talent vous allez bien
ah bah oui depuis le camp quand même
josette rouvrir des femmes - ah oui on
peut continuer patrick oui interview -
excusez moi mais c'est pas moi c'est
quoi j'ai été là ça serait bien donc
sans talent c'est marina
on est sûr c'est que la mission d'un
vaisseau d'équité pas alors voilà donc
on essaie on n'arrête pas de sonner
donc tu as des enfants lundi le
personnel chantal tu es en gp2 je te
repasse laurent je t'embrasse chantal
bisous et vous qu'on m'appelle pas jean
pierre pernaut h demain matin dans les
yeux je suis désolé je suis désolé ta
droite se refaire et à la dernière et
que c'est à dire écoute moi ouais du ps
avait dit oui l'arrivée je sais pas
éteint la lumière et un
ebit mois ferme et de lunettes de mouche
le chantait ma main
en suisse en brousse
j'écoutais
allez on raccroche à 3,1
3,3
biens dont donc
incroyable histoire non
les différences aboulker qui fait tout
pour lui qui nous présente le maquilleur
de david bowie qui vend son appartement
pour qu'il fasse son olympia l'huile la
trombe avec une gamine il la met
enceinte la gamine la gamine ne garde
pas l'enfant est aujourd'hui je le
regrette résultat des courses quand même
séparation d'avec florence aboulker
hélas début mon cher patrick juvet de
votre relation avec jean michel jarre et
c'est le scoop du livre vous dites
pendant deux ans on a dîné ensemble tous
les soirs jeudi est très proche quoi bon
on sait pas très bien quand on lit le
bouquin de 6 à u
tu es président tu cherches c'est clair
que tu cherches pénétrant soir sûr qu'on
n'a plus forcément tu me connais tu as
des
lycées c'est mon complice oui non on ne
sait pas mais match peut avoir des
fantasmes l'amener c'était pas son truc
ouais c'est jamais été son truc parce
que j'ai déjà engagé quand même cogné on
se fade et toute l'histoire adjani mme
jean michel jarre nancy patrick juvet
est ce que tu sais tu sais pas c'est que
lui il était amoureux de jean michel
c'est vrai j'étais amoureuse sous le
charme sous le charme mise en passant et
l'autre il était l'ingrédient et un jour
il arrive et lui dit voilà je vais te
dire j'étais à saint tropez ce week-end
j'ai rencontré une fille formidable qui
s'appelle charlotte rampling oui que je
l'avais dit d'aller voir voilà bah oui
elle est formidable j'avais mal à la wii
et les formidables sauf que lui se
retrouve tout seul et là il commence à
aller mal c'est à dire que plus de
fluence aboulker plus de jean michel
jarre il commence à sombrer dans
l'alcool et c'est le début de la
descente aux enfers de patrick juvet
voilà
enfin c'était il avait besoin d'oxygène
tout cas l'air
et moi si je suis parti aux états unis
et alors après voilà il ya l'épopée
américaine enfin c'est quand même un
grand roman sert que patrick arrive là
bas c'est l'époque de war de la factory
du gie de 54 et cetera hélas quand même
vous tapez le dj pour qu'ils passent à
l'america ou 54 à wimb à ba ba
oui mais oui non mais c'était jacques
lamy qui m'avait dit si tu veux tu en
dises en bresse si tu veux que ton
disque pas être copain avec le dj je
suis allé lui dire bonjour oui on
connaît la passion devient bon
non mais s'il en est en fait il était
hyper sympa il m'a dit mardi est ce que
tu es est ce que tu peux dîner avec moi
on a dîné ben voilà il a passé le dise
que c'est devenu un tube en amérique et
là alors là voilà là c'est le vrai
pétage de plombs parce que c'est
l'époque bon il ya le champagne la
cocaïne y les champignons hallucinogènes
ça mais c'est l'époque des quoi le 'jeu
pas si quelqu'un ici se souvient de ce
qu'était des couettes moitié morestin
soixante dix les quoi lui prenais sec de
l'alcool sa symphonie des contractants
fait voilà c'était terrible qu'on
mélange qu on nous mettait dans les
verres les attacher voilà ça des maisons
de disques pour consorts en pleine forme
pour les télés voilà on n'arrivait
vraiment bien arrêté et là vous tapez
melanie griffith
cet appui qui la nient les faits
le12 qui vo
c'est à dire que je voulais rencontrer
se voulait rencontrer je voulais
rencontrer invente quand votre livre je
voulais rencontrer les tippi hedren qui
a fait les oiseaux qui a joué dans coke
de pétrole est en fait on a dîné
ensemble elle est venue avec sa fille et
sa fille s'était mélanie et voilà et
puis ça a commencé comme ça comme ça
au studio fifty fort voilà sa durée à un
an voilà pied après bon il ya cinq ans
de désintox parce que vous vous dites ça
va durer trois semaines la désintox en
fait ça dure cinq ans
et vous attends là c'est un peu le côté
bizarre du livre vous avez le foie
pourri et là vous êtes opéré par un
guérisseur à mains nues qui a commis aux
philippines pierre lemay qui vous aux
bears sans vous ouvrir le ventre sans
déshabiller c'était un guérisseur et
puis j'y croyais pas trop et puis le
lendemain c'est vrai que j'ai eu une
fois gerber de partout et
ça m'a sauvé et aujourd'hui alors brut à
barcelone c'est ça oui ça se passe bien
très bien qui va vous voir à part
palmade qui descend à barcelone pour lui
dire bonjour
les amis khimki mickael qui ont envie de
venir prendre le soleil mais savait que
là où je suis c'est mon appartement
c'est plus un hôtel maintenant pour les
amis que car quelle morale vous tirer
toute cette histoire
j'ai eu de la chance vous avez gâché
votre talent ah non je crois que j'ai
toujours eu une bonne étoile et beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de chance parce que en
plus pendant ces années américaines j'ai
quand même faire 25 pays
parce que le disque est est disque d'or
dans 15 pays mais c'est tellement
fatigant et je pense que
ont baisé tout le monde du baiser tout
le monde sans savoir que le sida
existait et j'ai eu de la chance parce
que j'étais très fleur bleue
donc je n'ai pas chopé ouais je suis
toujours flore le il paye on vous avez
fait quoi abbas jeu j'étais invité
partout pour voir
c'était pas de la drogue on me faisait
voir beaucoup et mais seulement j'avais
au moins 30 personnes autour de moi
c'est moi qui payais
du jet privé tout ça tout est reconnue
riez pas c'est quoi
mais je regrette pas sa façon c'est ce
qui est emmerdant c'était après parce
qu'après bon il ya les droits à la sacem
un petit peu après sa baisse
jusqu'au jour je me suis retrouvé chez
mes parents
à 36 ans un stage j'avais un peu la
honte quand
vous avez fait des très belles chansons
patrick merci gentil et on vous
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu